Witaj ponownie w kursie „Zrozumieć informację i obliczenia kwantowe". Mam na imię John Watrous i jestem dyrektorem technicznym ds. edukacji w IBM
Quantum. To jest lekcja numer 15 serii i trzecia lekcja czwartej jednostki, poświęconej korekcji błędów
kwantowych. Do tej pory widzieliśmy kilka przykładów kwantowych kodów korekcji błędów, w tym 9-qubitowy kod Shore'a,
7-qubitowy kod Steane'a i 5-qubitowy kod, oraz omawialiśmy formalizm stabilizatora, który zapewnia
nam matematyczne podstawy do opisu i analizy tych i wielu innych kwantowych kodów korekcji
błędów. Kody, które właśnie wymieniłem, są bez wątpienia interesujące i stanowią naturalne miejsce do rozpoczęcia
eksploracji korekcji błędów kwantowych. Problem polega na tym, że mogą tolerować jedynie bardzo niski współczynnik błędów.
Korekcja błędu na jednym qubicie z pięciu, siedmiu lub dziewięciu nie jest zła, ale najprawdopodobniej – przynajmniej na ile podejrzewamy –
będziemy musieli tolerować o wiele więcej błędów, żeby obliczenia kwantowe na dużą skalę stały się
rzeczywistością. W tej lekcji przyjrzymy się po raz pierwszy bardziej zaawansowanym konstrukcjom kwantowych kodów korekcji błędów, w tym kodom, które mogą
tolerować znacznie wyższy współczynnik błędów niż te, które do tej pory widzieliśmy, i są uważane za obiecujących kandydatów do praktycznej korekcji błędów kwantowych w
rzeczywistych urządzeniach fizycznych. Oto krótki przegląd lekcji. Zaczniemy od klasy
kwantowych kodów korekcji błędów zwanych kodami CSS, nazwanej na cześć badaczy, którzy je jako pierwsi odkryli: Roberta Calderbanke'a, Petera
Shora i Andrew Steane'a. Konstrukcja kodu CSS pozwala wziąć pewne pary klasycznych
kodów korekcji błędów i połączyć je w kwantowy kod korekcji błędów. W ramach tej dyskusji
dość szybko przyjrzymy się klasycznym kodom liniowym, a także omówimy niektóre podstawowe właściwości kodów
CSS. Druga część lekcji dotyczy kodu zwanego kodem torycznym, który jest fundamentalnym i naprawdę
pięknym przykładem kwantowego kodu korekcji błędów, mogącego tolerować stosunkowo wysoki współczynnik błędów. W rzeczywistości
kod toryczny to nie jeden przykład kwantowego kodu korekcji błędów, lecz nieskończona rodzina kodów – jeden dla
każdej dodatniej liczby całkowitej zaczynając od dwóch. W ostatniej części lekcji krótko omówimy kilka innych
rodzin kodów kwantowych, w tym surface code'y, ściśle powiązane z kodem torycznym, a także
kody kolorów. Ludzie badają klasyczne kody korekcji błędów od lat czterdziestych XX wieku
i jest to fascynujący i bogaty temat. Kody liniowe są być może najprostszym typem klasycznych kodów korekcji
błędów, i zaraz dokładnie wyjaśnię, co słowo „liniowy" oznacza w tym kontekście. Ale jednym prostym
sposobem wyrażenia tego, czym są, jest to, że są kodami stabilizatora, które akurat są klasyczne, i wkrótce zobaczymy, że
kody CSS są zasadniczo parami klasycznych kodów liniowych połączonych razem, żeby stworzyć kwantowy kod
korekcji błędów. Na potrzeby tej dyskusji będziemy więc musieli rozumieć kilka podstawowych rzeczy o
klasycznych kodach liniowych. Przyjmiemy, że Σ to binarny alfabet dla całej tej
dyskusji. Teraz gdy mówimy o klasycznym kodzie liniowym, mamy na myśli zbiór C binarnych ciągów o długości n dla pewnej
dodatniej liczby całkowitej n spełniający jedną podstawową własność: jeśli u i v są binarnymi ciągami w C, to ciąg
u XOR v też jest w C. Przez u XOR v rozumiemy tu bitowe exclusive or u i v, tak jak
widzieliśmy wielokrotnie w lekcjach pięć i sześć, w części serii o algorytmach kwantowych. I to właśnie oznacza, że klasyczny
kod jest liniowy. W istocie myślimy o binarnych ciągach o długości n jako n-wymiarowych wektorach,
gdzie wszystkie elementy to zero lub jeden, ale zamiast zwykłego dodawania wektorów nad liczbami rzeczywistymi lub zespolonymi
używamy dodawania modulo 2, co jest po prostu XOR-em. Jeśli więc mamy
dwa słowa kodowe u i v, czyli u i v są binarnymi ciągami w C, to u + v modulo 2, czyli innymi słowy u XOR
v, musi też być słowem kodowym w C. Przy okazji ta implikacja musi być prawdziwa nawet jeśli U jest równe V – nic tego
nie wyklucza. I to implikuje, że każdy klasyczny kod liniowy musi zawierać ciąg zerowy, bo
bitowe XOR dowolnego ciągu z nim samym daje ciąg zerowy. Na przykład trzybinowy
kod repetycji jest klasycznym kodem liniowym. W szczególności są dwa możliwe wybory dla U i dwa możliwe
wybory dla V, i to dość trywialna sprawa przejść przez możliwe pary, żeby zobaczyć, że zawsze dostajemy słowo kodowe biorąc bitowe
XOR. Oto kolejny przykład, zwany kodem Hamminga [7,4,3]. Jest to jeden z bardzo pierwszych klasycznych kodów korekcji
błędów, jaki kiedykolwiek odkryto, i składa się z 16 binarnych ciągów o długości siedmiu. Istnieje bardzo prosta logika
wyboru tych ciągów, ale nie będę tego wyjaśniać w tym filmie, i powinienem też wspomnieć, że czasem możesz zobaczyć te ciągi odwrócone, ale
na razie najważniejsze jest to, że jeśli weźmiemy dowolne dwa z tych ciągów i zXOR-ujemy je razem, dostaniemy inny ciąg w
kodzie. Jest to więc kod liniowy. Notacja [7,4,3] w pojedynczych nawiasach kwadratowych oznacza coś analogicznego do podwójnej
notacji w nawiasach kwadratowych, o której wspomniałem w poprzedniej lekcji dla kodów stabilizatora, ale tutaj dotyczy klasycznych kodów
liniowych. W szczególności słowa kodowe mają siedem bitów, istnieje 16 słów kodowych, więc możemy zakodować cztery bity używając tego kodu, i
jest to kod o odległości trzy, co oznacza, że musisz odwrócić co najmniej trzy bity dowolnego słowa kodowego, żeby dostać
inne słowo kodowe, co implikuje, że może korygować do jednego błędu flipowania bitu. To są proste przykłady
kodów, ale nawet przykład kodu Hamminga [7,4,3] wygląda dość tajemniczo, gdy po prostu wylistujemy wszystkie słowa kodowe. Potrzebujemy lepszych sposobów
opisu klasycznych kodów liniowych, i istnieją dwa naturalne sposoby. Jednym sposobem jest opisanie klasycznych
kodów liniowych przez podanie minimalnego zestawu słów kodowych generujących kod, co oznacza, że biorąc wszystkie możliwe
podzbiory tych słów kodowych i XOR-ując je razem, dostajemy cały kod. Jest to wyrażone w terminach matematycznych
tutaj na ekranie. Innym sposobem myślenia o tym jest traktowanie tego kodu jako podprzestrzeni przestrzeni wektorowej i ten
zbiór generatorów jest bazą dla tej podprzestrzeni. Mając na uwadze, że jest to przestrzeń wektorowa z arytmetyką modulo 2. Jeśli mamy M generatorów,
dostaniemy kod z 2^M elementami. Każdy generator podwaja liczbę elementów kodu, i
to jest zgodne z faktem, że klasyczne kody liniowe nad binarnym alfabetem zawsze zawierają liczbę ciągów będącą potęgą
dwójki. Drugim naturalnym sposobem opisania klasycznego kodu liniowego są kontrole parzystości. Konkretnie jest to minimalna
lista binarnych ciągów o tej samej długości co ciągi w kodzie, takich że ciągi w kodzie to dokładnie te, których binarny
iloczyn skalarny z każdym z ciągów kontroli parzystości jest zerem, gdzie binarny iloczyn skalarny to po prostu zwykły
iloczyn wewnętrzny modulo 2. I znowu jest to coś, z czym zetknęliśmy się w lekcji pięć w kontekście algorytmów
zapytań. Ciągi te są nazywane ciągami kontroli parzystości, bo dany ciąg U ma binarny iloczyn skalarny równy
zeru z v wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy bity U odpowiadające jedynkom w V mają parzystą
parzystość. Gdy opisujemy klasyczny kod liniowy w ten sposób przy użyciu minimalnej listy ciągów kontroli parzystości, każdy ciąg kontroli parzystości
dzieli liczbę ciągów w kodzie przez dwa. Zatem dla jednego kodu opisanego na te dwa różne sposoby zawsze będziemy mieć m + r = n.
Ważna rzecz do zauważenia tutaj to fakt, że binarny iloczyn skalarny nie jest iloczynem wewnętrznym w sensie formalnym, i
w szczególności gdy dwa ciągi mają binarny iloczyn skalarny równy zeru, nie oznacza to, że są ortogonalne w zwykłym sensie, w jakim myślimy o
ortogonalności. Na przykład binarny iloczyn skalarny ciągu 1,1 z nim samym wynosi zero, więc możliwe jest, że
jeden z tych ciągów kontroli parzystości jest sam w sobie w kodzie. To tylko coś do
zapamiętania. Na przykład, jak już wiemy, 3-bitowy kod repetycji jest kodem liniowym, więc może być opisany na oba te
sposoby. W szczególności istnieje tylko jeden wybór generatora, który działa, i jest to 1,1,1, a alternatywnie możemy opisać
kod przy użyciu tych dwóch ciągów kontroli parzystości, które powinny wyglądać znajomo z naszych poprzednich dyskusji o tym
kodzie. A dla kodu Hamminga [7,4,3] możemy użyć tych generatorów i tych kontroli
parzystości. Przy okazji, tutaj wszystkie nasze ciągi kontroli parzystości okazują się same w sobie być w kodzie.
Końcowy komentarz o klasycznych kodach liniowych, by połączyć je z formalizmem stabilizatora: te ciągi kontroli parzystości
są równoważne generatorom stabilizatora, gdzie mamy tylko macierze Pauliego Z i identyczność. Na przykład ciągi kontroli parzystości
1,1,0 i 0,1,1 dla 3-bitowego kodu repetycji odpowiadają dokładnie generatorom stabilizatora ZZ⊗I
i I⊗ZZ, co jest zgodne z naszą dyskusją o obserwowalnych tego rodzaju z poprzedniej
lekcji. Następnie omówimy kody CSS, które są kodami stabilizatora, które można uzyskać, łącząc ze sobą pewne
pary klasycznych kodów liniowych o tej samej liczbie bitów w ich kodowaniach. Nie działa to dla dowolnych dwóch
klasycznych kodów liniowych – dwa kody muszą mieć pewną zależność, jak wkrótce zobaczymy, ale mimo to ta
konstrukcja otwiera wiele możliwości dla kwantowych kodów korekcji błędów, opartych po części na tym, czego dowiedzieliśmy się przez ponad 75 lat
klasycznej teorii kodowania. Wspomniałem już, że w formalizmie stabilizatora generatory stabilizatora
zawierające tylko macierze Pauliego Z i identyczność są równoważne kontrolom parzystości. Na przykład w 3-bitowym
kodzie repetycji możemy użyć ciągów kontroli parzystości 1,1,0 i 0,1,1, które wymuszają, że dwa lewe bity są
równe, a dwa prawe bity są równe, dla każdego ciągu w kodzie. Te dwa ciągi kontroli parzystości odpowiadają dokładnie generatorom stabilizatora
ZZ⊗I i I⊗ZZ. Dla kodu Hamminga [7,4,3] możemy użyć
tych ciągów kontroli parzystości, które odpowiadają tym generatorom stabilizatora, gdzie po prostu zastępujemy każdą jedynkę przez Z, a każde zero przez identyczność.
Możesz rozpoznać te generatory stabilizatora, bo są to trzy z sześciu generatorów stabilizatora dla 7-qubitowego kodu Steane'a.
To z pewnością nie jest przypadek i wkrótce zobaczymy, co tu dokładnie zachodzi. Nazwiemy
generatorami Z-stabilizatora generatory stabilizatora zawierające tylko czynniki tensorowe Pauliego Z i identyczności.
Zatem X i Y nigdy nie pojawiają się w generatorze Z-stabilizatora. Możemy też rozważyć
generatory stabilizatora, w których pojawiają się tylko macierze Pauliego X i identyczności, i możemy myśleć o takich generatorach stabilizatora jako całkowicie analogicznych
do generatorów Z-stabilizatora, z tą różnicą, że zasadniczo opisują kontrole parzystości w bazie plus-minus, a nie w
standardowej bazie. Na przykład wracając do kodu Hamminga [7,4,3], możemy pomyśleć o
pozostałych trzech generatorach stabilizatora z 7-qubitowego kodu Steane'a, które akurat podążają dokładnie tym samym wzorcem co generatory Z-stabilizatora dla tego
kodu, ale tym razem podstawiamy X za jedynkę zamiast Z. I co dostajemy z samych tych trzech generatorów stabilizatora
to kod zawierający 16 stanów pokazanych tutaj, które uzyskujemy stosując gate'y Hadamard do stanów standardowej
bazy odpowiadających ciągom w kodzie Hamminga [7,4,3]. I oczywiście nasza przestrzeń kodowa zawiera też
kombinacje liniowe tych stanów. Naturalnie generatory stabilizatora tej formy są nazywane generatorami X-stabilizatora –
tym razem nie mogą pojawiać się żadne Y ani Z. Teraz możemy zdefiniować kody CSS w
prostych słowach: kody CSS to kody stabilizatora, które można wyrazić używając tylko
generatorów Z-stabilizatora i generatorów X-stabilizatora, bez żadnych Y, i bez X i Z pojawiających się w tym samym generatorze
stabilizatora. Żeby upewnić się, że jest to jasne, powinniśmy pamiętać, że istnieje swoboda wyboru generatorów stabilizatora dla kodów
stabilizatora, i ta definicja mówi, że kod CSS to taki, dla którego możliwe jest wybranie tylko generatorów Z i X stabilizatora.
Ale w ogólności mógłbyś wybrać inne generatory stabilizatora, które mogą nie być generatorami Z lub X stabilizatora, jeśli
chcesz. Oto mniej więcej najprostszy nietrywialny przykład kodu CSS, jaki możemy mieć, gdzie jest zarówno generator
Z-stabilizatora, jak i generator X-stabilizatora, i zweryfikowanie tego nie wymaga niczego więcej niż spojrzenia, skoro wiemy już z
poprzedniej lekcji, że jest to ważny kod stabilizatora. Przestrzeń kodowa jest jednowymiarowa – to przestrzeń rozpięta przez stan
Bella φ⁺ – i możemy zauważyć, że nasze dwa generatory stabilizatora działają trywialnie na tym wektorze, rozważając
dwa wyrażenia ebita pokazane na ekranie, wraz z interpretacją generatorów stabilizatora jako kontroli parzystości w bazach 0-1
i plus-minus. 7-qubitowy kod Steane'a to kolejny przykład kodu CSS, bo dla tego
wyboru generatorów mamy tylko generatory Z i X stabilizatora. I znowu wiemy już, że jest to ważny
kod stabilizatora. 9-qubitowy kod Shore'a to kolejny przykład: tym razem mamy sześć generatorów
Z-stabilizatora i tylko dwa generatory X-stabilizatora, i to jest w porządku – nie musi być równowagi ani symetrii
między tymi dwoma typami. Jest jednak kluczowe, że faktycznie mamy ważny kod stabilizatora, co oznacza,
że każdy z generatorów Z-stabilizatora musi komutować z każdym z generatorów X-stabilizatora. Nie możesz więc
po prostu niezależnie wybierać obu typów generatorów, i powiem o tym trochę więcej w dalszej części lekcji. Następnie omówimy wykrywanie
i korekcję błędów dla kodów CSS, i okaże się, że własność, którą zaobserwowaliśmy dla 9-qubitowego kodu Shore'a –
że możemy niezależnie wykrywać i korygować błędy X i Z – zachodzi w ogólności dla kodów CSS.
Żeby wyjaśnić to dalej, rozważmy kod CSS, taki jak 7-qubitowy kod Steane'a, ale może to być inny kod CSS, jeśli
wolisz. Podstawowa idea jest taka, że generatory Z-stabilizatora wykrywają błędy X,
ale są całkowicie ślepe na błędy Z, bo generatory Z-stabilizatora zawsze komutują z błędami Z.
Ponadto generatory Z-stabilizatora komutują też z cokolwiek gate'ów Z możemy chcieć zastosować jako
korekcje dla błędów Z. Podobnie generatory X-stabilizatora wykrywają błędy Z, ale są całkowicie
ślepe na błędy X i korekcje. Możemy więc w istocie myśleć o generatorach Z-stabilizatora jako reprezentujących klasyczny
kod liniowy chroniący przed bit flipami, czyli błędami X, natomiast generatory X-stabilizatora
reprezentują klasyczny kod liniowy w bazie plus-minus całkowicie niezależnie chroniący przed flipami
między stanami plus i minus, czyli błędami phase flip, czyli błędami Z. Teraz jest już całkiem oczywiste, co się
dzieje z kodem Steane'a: jest to po prostu kod Hamminga [7,4,3] dla błędów bit flip i kod Hamminga [7,4,3] dla błędów phase flip.
Znowu – fakt, że generatory Z-stabilizatora i generatory X-stabilizatora komutują, jest wymagany.
Nie byłby to ważny kod stabilizatora, gdyby nie komutowały. Można by powiedzieć, że to szczęście, że kod Hamminga [7,4,3]
działa w ten sposób, ale istnieje wiele innych możliwych wyborów par klasycznych kodów liniowych, które dadzą nam ważny kod stabilizatora
po połączeniu w ten sposób. Wracając więc do kodów CSS w ogólności, załóżmy, że generatory
Z-stabilizatora pozwalają na korekcję do, powiedzmy, J błędów X, a generatory X-stabilizatora pozwalają na korekcję do
K błędów Z. W przypadku kodu Steane'a J i K wynoszą obydwa jeden, bo
kod Hamminga [7,4,3] może korygować jeden bit flip. Ale w ogólności te liczby J i K mogą być różne.
Wynika z tego przez dyskretyzację błędów, że kod CSS może korygować dowolny błąd na liczbie qubitów co najwyżej
równej minimum z J i K. Dzieje się tak dlatego, że gdy mierzymy syndrom, dowolny błąd na pewnej
liczbie qubitów probabilistycznie kolapsuje do jakiejś kombinacji błędów X, Z lub obu, a następnie
błędy X i Z mogą być wykrywane i korygowane niezależnie. Zatem o ile mamy dwa
klasyczne kody liniowe, które współgrają ze sobą w sensie, że dają nam komutujące generatory X i Z stabilizatora,
kod CSS, który uzyskujemy przez ich połączenie, zasadniczo dziedziczy własności korekcji błędów obu kodów w sensie, który właśnie
opisałem. Zauważ, że jest pewna cena do zapłacenia, polegająca na tym, że nie możemy zakodować tylu qubitów, ile moglibyśmy bitów
przy dwóch klasycznych kodach, bo łączna liczba generatorów stabilizatora dla kodu CSS jest sumą
liczby kontroli parzystości dla dwóch klasycznych kodów, a każdy generator stabilizatora zmniejsza wymiar przestrzeni kodowej
o połowę. Na przykład kod Hamminga [7,4,3] pozwala na kodowanie czterech klasycznych bitów, bo mamy tylko
trzy kontrole parzystości dla tego kodu, natomiast 7-qubitowy kod Steane'a koduje tylko jeden qubit, bo ma sześć
generatorów stabilizatora. Ostatnią rzeczą, którą wyjaśnię o kodach CSS w ogólności w tej lekcji, są przestrzenie kodowe kodów CSS
i jak wyglądają, i da nam to też możliwość dokładniejszego zbadania zależności, która musi zachodzić między
dwoma klasycznymi kodami liniowymi, żeby były kompatybilne w sensie, że możemy je połączyć, tworząc kod
CSS. Rozważmy dowolny kod CSS na N qubitach i niech Z₁ do Z_s będą n-bitowymi
ciągami kontroli parzystości odpowiadającymi generatorom Z-stabilizatora. Oznacza to, że klasyczny
kod liniowy opisany przez generatory Z-stabilizatora, który nazwiemy C_Z, by pomóc nam pamiętać, że
jest to kod odpowiadający generatorom Z-stabilizatora, ma formę pokazaną tutaj na ekranie. Słownie, kod zawiera każdy
ciąg U, którego binarny iloczyn skalarny z każdym z ciągów kontroli parzystości wynosi zero. Jeśli chcielibyśmy, moglibyśmy też
rozważyć inny kod wyprowadzony z tych samych ciągów, który nazwiemy D_Z, i idea jest taka, że myślimy o
ciągach Z₁ do Z_s nie jako o ciągach kontroli parzystości, lecz jako o generatorach.
Na tym etapie nie jest jasne, dlaczego chcielibyśmy myśleć o tym kodzie, ale możemy to zrobić i okaże się to istotne dla tej
dyskusji. Ten kod jest nazywany kodem dualnym C_Z i jest powszechnie oznaczany C_Z⊥, co oznacza C_Z z symbolem prostopadłości
jako indeksem górnym, ale będziemy go nazywać D_Z, co będzie łatwe do zapamiętania, bo D jest skrótem od
dualny. Możemy też zrobić coś podobnego z generatorami X-stabilizatora. Tym razem C_X to klasyczny kod liniowy,
którego ciągi kontroli parzystości odpowiadają generatorom X-stabilizatora, a D_X to kod dualny tego kodu. Nawiasem mówiąc,
możemy teraz opisać warunki, które muszą zachodzić, żeby C_Z i C_X były kompatybilne w sensie, że możemy je
sparować jako kod CSS. W kategoriach samych tych kodów musi być spełnione, że
D_Z jest zawarty w C_X, lub równoważnie, że D_X jest zawarty w C_Z. Teraz jest
możliwe opisanie przestrzeni kodowej kodu CSS wyprowadzonego z tych dwóch kodów, i jednym ze sposobów jej opisania jest to, że
jest to przestrzeń rozpięta przez wszystkie wektory mające formę pokazaną tutaj na ekranie. Słowami, wyglądają jak równomierne
superpozycje po ciągach w kodzie dualnym D_X, kodu odpowiadającego generatorom X-stabilizatora, przesuniętych
lub zXOR-owanych z ciągami w kodzie C_Z odpowiadającym generatorom Z-stabilizatora, i zobaczymy, jak to wygląda
w konkretnym przypadku kodu Steane'a za chwilę. Sens jest taki, że stany w przestrzeni kodowej muszą być
wektorami własnymi z wartością +1 dla wszystkich generatorów stabilizatora, a w szczególności mnożenie przez dowolny z
generatorów X-stabilizatora jest równoważne zXOR-owaniu przez odpowiadający ciąg X. Dlatego właśnie te równomierne superpozycje
po D_X przesuniętych przez różne ciągi pojawiają się w ten sposób. Różne wybory przesunięcia,
reprezentowane przez ciąg Y w tym wyrażeniu, mogą nawiasem mówiąc dawać ten sam wektor, więc te stany nie są wszystkie różne, ale łącznie obejmują
całą przestrzeń kodową. Istnieje tutaj symetria między generatorami X i Z stabilizatora
i kodami, które im odpowiadają, i możemy użyć tej symetrii do opisania wektorów w przestrzeni kodowej w analogiczny sposób, zamieniając X na Z, ale
musimy też zamienić standardowe bazy na bazy plus-minus, dlatego właśnie operacje Hadamard pojawiają się w tym
wyrażeniu. Teraz dla obiecanego przykładu, którym jest kod Steane'a, dostajemy te dwa zakodowane możliwe
kodowania stanów zero i jeden w standardowej bazie. W szczególności możemy zakodować stan zero jako równomierną
superpozycję po ośmiu ciągach w kodzie dualnym kodu Hamminga [7,4,3], który okazuje się być połową ciągów w kodzie Hamminga [7,4,3], i
możemy zakodować stan jeden w podobny sposób, z tą różnicą, że wszystkie ciągi są zXOR-owane z ciągiem samych jedynek w tym przypadku.
Dzieje się tak, bo ten ciąg akurat jest w kodzie Hamminga [7,4,3], ale nie w jego kodzie dualnym. Ostatni komentarz tutaj jest taki, że często
nie zależy nam zbyt wiele na tym, jak wyglądają wektory w naszych przestrzeniach kodowych, bo zazwyczaj nie musimy tego wiedzieć, żeby
używać kodów. Jeśli więc to wyjaśnienie nie było jasne, naprawdę nie ma się czym martwić, ale jest oczywiście
naturalne, żeby zapytać, jak wyglądają wektory w przestrzeniach kodowych kodów CSS, i ten opis daje odpowiedź na to
pytanie. Następnie omówimy konkretny kod CSS zwany kodem torycznym, który jest przykładem czegoś zwanego topologicznym
kwantowym kodem korekcji błędów. Ten kod został odkryty przez Aleksieja Kitajewa w
1997 roku. W rzeczywistości kod toryczny to nie jeden kod, lecz rodzina kodów, jeden dla każdej dodatniej liczby całkowitej co
najmniej dwa. Kody te mają pewne kluczowe własności. Pierwszą kluczową własnością jest
to, że wszystkie generatory stabilizatora mają małą wagę jako operacje Pauliego – w szczególności wszystkie będą miały
wagę cztery. Jest to korzystne, bo oznacza, że każdy pomiar generatora stabilizatora nie musi
angażować zbyt wielu qubitów. Czasem ludzie mówią o kwantowych kodach LDPC, czyli kwantowych kodach kontroli parzystości
niskiej gęstości, i to właśnie oznacza ten termin – gdzie w tym przypadku „mała" oznacza cztery. Zatem kod toryczny to przykład kwantowego
kodu LDPC. Kod toryczny ma też tak zwaną geometryczną lokalność, co oznacza, że nie
tylko generatory stabilizatora mają małą wagę, ale też możliwe jest rozmieszczenie qubitów w przestrzeni tak, że
każdy pomiar generatora stabilizatora angażuje tylko qubity, które są blisko siebie, co sprawia, że te pomiary są w zasadzie łatwiejsze do zaimplementowania
w praktyce. I wreszcie kody te mają dużą odległość, więc mogą tolerować stosunkowo wysoki współczynnik
błędów. Oto jak działają te kody. Niech L będzie dodatnią
liczbą całkowitą co najmniej dwa, i rozważmy siatkę L × L z tak zwanymi periodycznymi
brzegami. Na przykład oto siatka L × L dla L=8, i zauważ, że linie
po prawej i na dole są liniami przerywanymi. Chodzi o to, żeby myśleć o przerywkowej linii po prawej jako tej samej linii, co
linia po lewej, i podobnie przerywkowa linia na dole jest tą samą linią co ta na
górze. Gdybyśmy faktycznie chcieli fizycznie zrealizować taką konfigurację, potrzebowalibyśmy trzech
wymiarów. W szczególności moglibyśmy uformować cylinder, najpierw dopasowując lewy i prawy brzeg, a następnie zgiąć
cylinder tak, żeby koła na końcach, które były górnym i dolnym brzegiem siatki, spotkały się, lub
możesz najpierw dopasować górę i dół, a potem boki – działa to w obie strony i nie ma znaczenia, jak to robisz na potrzeby tej
dyskusji. To, co dostajemy, to torus, czyli innymi mówiąc pączek, choć myślenie o nim jako o dętce do opony może być
lepszym obrazem, bo to nie jest wydrążony obiekt – siatka stała się właśnie powierzchnią
torusa. I stąd pochodzi nazwa „kod toryczny". Sposób poruszania się po
torusie jak tym, zakładając, że możesz poruszać się między sąsiednimi punktami siatki, będzie prawdopodobnie znajomy osobom, które grały w oldschoolowe gry wideo,
gdzie jeśli przejdziesz poza górny brzeg ekranu, pojawiasz się na dole, i podobnie dla lewego i prawego brzegu
ekranu. I w większości właśnie w ten sposób będę opisywał tę siatkę, zamiast mówić konkretnie o torusie
w trójwymiarowej przestrzeni. Następnie wyobrażamy sobie, że qubity są
umieszczone na krawędziach siatki, jak zilustrowano tutaj na ekranie, gdzie qubity są wskazane przez solidne niebieskie
kółka. Zauważ przy okazji, że qubity umieszczone na przerywkowych liniach nie są solidne, i dzieje się tak, bo te qubity są już reprezentowane
przez te wzdłuż górnego lub lewego brzegu, mając na uwadze, że linie na górze i po lewej to dokładnie te same linie, co
wskazane przez przerywkowe linie na dole i po prawej. I jeśli policzymy wszystkie te qubity, dostajemy 2×L² qubitów, i jednym
ze sposobów na to jest obserwacja, że dostajemy L² qubitów na poziomych krawędziach i L² qubitów na pionowych
krawędziach. Oto więc rozmieszczenie naszych qubitów, i żeby opisać sam kod toryczny, wystarczy opisać generatory
stabilizatora. Istnieją dwa ich typy. Najpierw mamy generatory Z-stabilizatora –
odpowiadają one kafelkom lub płytkom na rysunku. Po drugie mamy generatory X-stabilizatora –
odpowiadają one wierzchołkom na rysunku. Na przykład oto jeden
generator stabilizatora, co oznacza, że składamy razem po jednej operacji Pauliego Z dla każdego z qubitów dotykających ten kafelek, wraz z macierzami identyczności
na wszystkich pozostałych qubitach, i to daje nam operację Pauliego wagi cztery. Oto przykład generatora
X-stabilizatora, gdzie macierze Pauliego X działają na czterech qubitach przylegających do tego wierzchołka, wraz z
macierzami identyczności na wszystkich pozostałych qubitach. Znowu jest to operacja Pauliego wagi cztery. Ważne jest, że w obu
typach generatorów stabilizatora uwzględniamy te zawijające się na periodycznych brzegach, i oto przykład generatora X-stabilizatora,
który to robi. Teraz żeby uzyskać ważny kod stabilizatora, potrzebujemy, żeby generatory stabilizatora
komutowały. Generatory Z-stabilizatora komutują ze sobą nawzajem, bo Z komutuje ze sobą, a identyczność
komutuje ze wszystkim. Podobnie dla generatorów X-stabilizatora. Jest też oczywiste, że generator Z-stabilizatora i generator X-stabilizatora
komutują, gdy działają nietrywialnie na rozłącznych zbiorach qubitów, tak jak dla dwóch generatorów pokazanych
tutaj. Pozostała możliwość to taka, że generator Z-stabilizatora i generator X-stabilizatora nachodzą na siebie, i
gdy to się dzieje, zawsze chodzi o dwa qubity, na których się nachodzą, więc generatory stabilizatora komutują, bo ZZ
i XX komutują. To nie jest minimalny zbiór generatorów stabilizatora. W szczególności jeśli pomnożymy
wszystkie generatory Z-stabilizatora razem, dostajemy identyczność, bo każdy qubit jest mnożony przez Z dwa razy –
raz dla każdego kafelka dotykającego ten qubit. Oznacza to, że mnożenie wszystkich generatorów Z-stabilizatora razem
poza jednym daje ten ostatni, więc nie są niezależne. Ale jeśli usuniemy którykolwiek z nich, dostaniemy
niezależny zbiór, i to samo jest prawdą dla generatorów X-stabilizatora. Zatem możemy usunąć jeden z każdego
i nie ma znaczenia, które usuwamy. Zostawia to L²-1 generatorów każdego typu. Żeby było jasne –
i to jest coś, o czym napomknąłem w poprzedniej lekcji – faktycznie zależy nam na wszystkich tych generatorach stabilizatora, i w ściśle
operacyjnym sensie nie będziemy faktycznie wybierać jednego z każdego typu do zignorowania, ale na potrzeby analizy kodu możemy
sobie wyobrazić, że jeden generator stabilizatora każdego typu został usunięty, żeby uzyskać minimalny zbiór generujący, mając na uwadze,
że zawsze możemy wywnioskować wyniki tych usuniętych generatorów, traktując je jako obserwowalne, z wyników wszystkich pozostałych generatorów
stabilizatora tego samego typu. Zatem liczba qubitów, które ten kod koduje, jest równa łącznej liczbie
qubitów, która wynosi 2×L², minus łączna liczba generatorów stabilizatora w minimalnym zbiorze generującym, która wynosi 2×L²-
1×2, co oznacza, że możemy zakodować 2 qubity. Nie argumentowałem nawiasem mówiąc, że przestrzeń kodowa jest nietrywialny, ale rzeczywiście
jest nietrywialny, i pozostawiam ci przekonanie się samodzielnie, że nie ma sposobu na pomnożenie razem generatorów stabilizatora w taki sposób, który dałby nam
-1 razy identyczność. I to jest sam kod toryczny – i w tym momencie może wcale nie być
jasne, dlaczego ten kod powinien być dobry do kwantowej korekcji błędów. Musimy go jeszcze przeanalizować, i co odkryjemy, to że jest to naprawdę
zadziwiający kwantowy kod korekcji błędów. Żeby zrozumieć, jak kod toryczny funkcjonuje jako kwantowy kod korekcji
błędów, zaczniemy od rozważenia różnych błędów i syndromów, które generują. Pierwsza rzecz do zauważenia to fakt, że
kod toryczny jest kodem CSS, bo wszystkie nasze generatory stabilizatora są albo generatorami Z, albo X stabilizatora,
i co to oznacza, to że błędy X i Z mogą być wykrywane i ewentualnie korygowane
oddzielnie. I w rzeczywistości istnieje prosta symetria między generatorami Z i X stabilizatora, która pozwala nam analizować błędy X
i Z w zasadniczo ten sam sposób. Skupię się więc na błędach X, które mogą być wykrywane przez generatory
Z-stabilizatora, i możesz przełożyć wszystko na błędy Z, które mogą być wykrywane przez generatory X-stabilizatora, używając dokładnie
tych samych idei. Oto rysunek ilustrujący nasze dwa kwadratowe qubity na krawędziach siatki L
na L z periodycznymi brzegami, i możemy sobie wyobrazić, że jest ona rozłożona na powierzchni
torusa. W tej chwili wszystkie qubity są niebieskie, co wskazuje, że nie zostały dotknięte przez
błędy. Powinieneś więc sobie wyobrazić, że w tym momencie stan tych qubitów jest w przestrzeni kodowej
dla tego kodu. Jak wspomniałem, skupimy się na błędach X, i za chwilę użyjemy magentowych kółek, żeby wskazać qubity, które
zostały dotknięte przez błędy X. Błędy X są wykrywane przez generatory Z-stabilizatora, które odpowiadają
kafelkom na rysunku. Możemy więc pozwolić białym kafelkom wskazywać wyniki pomiaru +1, czyli innymi słowy
wpisy w syndromie odpowiadające temu generatorowi, natomiast szare kafelki będą wskazywać wyniki pomiaru -1.
Możesz myśleć o wyniku +1, czyli o białym kafelku, jako wskazującym, że odpowiadający
generator stabilizatora jest zadowolony – wszystko wydaje się być w porządku dla tego generatora. Cóż, wynik -1, czyli szary kafelek,
wskazuje, że odpowiadający generator stabilizatora jest niezadowolony, bo oczywiście musiał pojawić się błąd, który spowodował ten
wynik. Zatem w tej chwili wszystkie nasze generatory stabilizatora są zadowolone, bo nie pojawił się żaden błąd. Jeśli teraz pomyślimy
o generatorze Z-stabilizatora, robi on tylko tyle, że mierzy parzystość 4 qubitów dotykających kafelek ze względu
na standardową bazę. Wynik +1 nie wskazuje zatem, że na tych czterech qubitach nie pojawiły się żadne błędy X,
lecz wskazuje, że pojawiła się parzysta liczba błędów X, natomiast wynik -1 wskazuje,
że pojawiła się nieparzysta liczba błędów X. Teraz wprowadźmy błąd X i zobaczmy, co się
dzieje. Dwa generatory Z-stabilizatora odpowiadające kafelkom dotykającym ten qubit są teraz niezadowolone, bo ten
błąd X antykomutuje z oboma tymi generatorami, lub równoważnie w kategoriach standardowej bazy – jesteśmy teraz w
stanie, gdzie oba te zestawy czterech qubitów odpowiadające dwóm kafelkom mają nieparzystą parzystość. Taki jest więc efekt pojedynczego
błędu X. Gdybyśmy zmierzyli ten syndrom i wiedzielibyśmy lub zakładalibyśmy, że pojawił się tylko jeden błąd X, moglibyśmy łatwo
wywnioskować, który qubit się odwrócił, i moglibyśmy po prostu go odwrócić z powrotem gate'em X. Zobaczmy teraz, co się dzieje,
gdy wprowadzamy dodatkowe błędy X, a w szczególności zobaczmy, co się dzieje, gdy drugi błąd X pojawia się na innym
qubicie dotykającym jeden z szarych kafelków – powiedzmy szary kafelek na górze.
Ten kafelek jest teraz zadowolony, bo na qubitach dotykających ten kafelek pojawiły się dwa błędy X, a dwa to liczba parzysta.
Te dwa błędy X razem komutują z generatorem stabilizatora dla tego kafelka. Inaczej mówiąc,
ten drugi błąd X przesunął wszystkie stany standardowej bazy tych czterech qubitów z nieparzystej parzystości z powrotem do parzystej
parzystości. Kafelek po lewej od tego nowego błędu X jest z kolei teraz niezadowolony.
Możemy kontynuować ten proces dodawania nowych błędów X, i o ile tworzymy łańcuch sąsiednich błędów X, gdzie sąsiedni oznacza, że qubity dotykają
ten sam kafelek, efektywnie przepychamy ten wynik pomiaru -1 i co odkrywamy, to że zawsze mamy
wyniki pomiaru syndromu -1 na końcach łańcuchów sąsiednich błędów. Zawsze więc możemy wykrywać łańcuchy
sąsiednich błędów X o ile mają końce – mogą nawiasem mówiąc istnieć wielokrotne łańcuchy, ale do tej możliwości
wrócimy później. Możliwe jest jednak, że mamy łańcuch sąsiednich błędów X, który
nie ma końców – czyli nasz łańcuch błędów może tworzyć zamkniętą pętlę. Dodajmy więc więcej błędów tak,
żeby tworzyły zamkniętą pętlę w ten sposób. Mamy teraz na przykład parzystą liczbę błędów X
na każdym kafelku, więc każdy generator stabilizatora jest teraz zadowolony. I odkryliśmy, że zamknięte
pętle sąsiednich błędów X nie są wykrywane przez ten kod, bo uzyskujemy syndrom samych +1 w takim
przypadku. To może wydawać się trochę rozczarowujące – w rzeczywistości potrzebujemy tylko czterech sąsiednich błędów X, żeby uformować zamkniętą pętlę,
i liczymy na coś lepszego niż kod o odległości 4. Jednak niektóre zamknięte pętle
sąsiednich błędów X są same w sobie w stabilizatorze. Pamiętaj, że mamy generator X-stabilizatora dla każdego wierzchołka w
siatce, i jeśli pomnożymy razem sąsiednie generatory X-stabilizatora, możemy tworzyć zamknięte pętle operacji
X, jak te tutaj, dla zamkniętej pętli, którą przed chwilą skonstruowaliśmy. Zatem niektóre zamknięte pętle błędów X,
jak ta pokazana tutaj, nie są w ogóle błędami, bo są w stabilizatorze, więc nie robią nic przestrzeni kodowej. Istnieją jednak
niektóre zamknięte pętle błędów X, które nie są w stabilizatorze, i dlatego reprezentują nietrywial błędy, które nie są wykrywane przez kod,
i istnieje dość prosty sposób scharakteryzowania różnych typów
pętli. Pętle przechodzące przez każdą linię w siatce – czyli każdą pionową linię od góry do dołu i każdą poziomą linię
od lewej do prawej – parzystą liczbę razy, są zawsze iloczynami generatorów X-stabilizatora. To dotyczy przykładu
pokazanego na ekranie, jak również pętli, które mogą być znacznie bardziej skomplikowane, w tym możliwości, że przechodzą przez periodyczne brzegi, ale
mimo to, mnożąc te zamknięte pętle błędów X przez generatory X-stabilizatora, można je efektywnie skurczyć do
niczego. I z pewnością prawdą jest, że możemy uzyskać tylko pętle w ten sposób przez mnożenie razem generatorów X-stabilizatora, bo każdy generator X-stabilizatora
umieszcza parzystą liczbę operacji X na każdej poziomej linii i na każdej pionowej
linii. Drugi typ zamkniętej pętli, jaki możemy mieć, to taki, który przechodzi przez co najmniej jedną linię nieparzystą liczbę razy, jak
ten tutaj pokazany, który przechodzi przez każdą poziomą linię dokładnie raz. I oto kolejny przykład przechodzący przez
każdą pionową linię dokładnie raz. To są więc przykłady nietrywialnych błędów, które nie są wykrywane przez kod. Ale kluczem
jest to, że jedynym sposobem na uformowanie zamkniętej pętli w ten sposób jest obejście torusa dookoła – albo wokół dziury w
środku torusa, albo przez dziurę, lub może przez obie. To jest własność topologiczna
dotycząca torusów – chodzi w zasadzie o dziury, i dlatego to jest nazywane topologicznym kwantowym kodem korekcji
błędów. W tej wizualizacji dwuwymiarowej siatki z periodycznymi brzegami łańcuch w tej kategorii musi
okrążać jeden lub oba periodyczne brzegi w sposób, który sprawia, że niemożliwe jest ściągnięcie tej pętli do
punktu przez mnożenie przez generatory X-stabilizatora. Taki łańcuch może być bardziej
skomplikowany niż ten zilustrowany tutaj, ale to jest najkrótszy, jaki taka pętla może być, bo musi jakoś okrążyć
jeden lub oba periodyczne brzegi. I co to implikuje, to że minimalna waga nietrywialnego
niewykrywalnego błędu wynosi L. Każda zamknięta pętla z mniejszą liczbą błędów musi należeć do pierwszej kategorii, i dlatego jest
w stabilizatorze. A łańcuchy błędów, które nie tworzą zamkniętych pętli, są wykrywane przez kod. I to wszystko – właśnie dlatego ten kod
działa. W rezultacie dostajemy stabilizatorowy kod [[2L², 2, L]] – używamy 2L² qubitów do kodowania
2 qubitów, a kod ma odległość L. Następnie powiem tylko trochę o
korygowaniu błędów przy użyciu kodu torycznego, choć nie będę wchodzić zbyt głęboko w szczegóły. Jeśli zmierzymy syndrom i
zobaczymy coś innego niż syndrom samych +1 – mówię tu tylko o generatorach Z-stabilizatora –
to wyniki -1 wskazują nam końce jednego lub więcej łańcuchów sąsiednich błędów X, i możemy próbować korygować
te błędy, parując ze sobą wyniki -1 i tworząc łańcuch korekcji X między nimi. I
robiąc to, sensowne jest wybieranie najkrótszych ścieżek dla naszych korekcji. Na przykład jeśli zmierzymy
syndrom taki, jak pokazany tutaj, moglibyśmy wybrać tę ścieżkę między niezadowolonymi kafelkami i aplikować gate'y X
jako korekcje wzdłuż tej ścieżki. Oczywiście faktyczny łańcuch błędów powodujący syndrom mógł być
inny, jak ten pokazany tutaj, ale to jest w porządku – o ile błędy i korekcje razem
należą do stabilizatora. Może się też zdarzyć, że nasze korekcje domykają pętlę wokół
torusa, co jest złe, bo robiąc to, spowodowaliśmy błąd logiczny. Zatem ta strategia korygowania
wzdłuż najkrótszych ścieżek koryguje błędy o małej wadze, ale może nie działać dla błędów o większej wadze. Oczywiście nie możemy
spodziewać się niczego więcej od żadnego kwantowego kodu korekcji błędów. Bardziej prawdopodobne – zależnie od modelu szumów –
jest to, że obserwujemy wiele -1 w syndromie. W tym przypadku możemy użyć efektywnych klasycznych algorytmów, żeby
sparować je i znaleźć błąd o najniższej wadze reprezentujący syndrom. Jak wspomniałem w poprzedniej
lekcji, nie zawsze koryguje to najbardziej prawdopodobne wyjaśnienie syndromu, ale działa dość dobrze w ogólności
i zawsze skutecznie koryguje błędy o wadze ściśle mniejszej niż połowa odległości L. Powinienem też
wspomnieć, że istnieją inne strategie lepiej dostosowane do różnych modeli błędów. Minęło już ponad 25 lat od odkrycia
kodu torycznego i przez ten czas wykonano sporo pracy nad kwantowymi kodami korekcji błędów, w tym
innymi topologicznymi kwantowymi kodami korekcji błędów zainspirowanymi kodem torycznym, jak również kodami opartymi na innych
pomysłach. Z pewnością nie mogę dać wyczerpującej listy wszystkich znanych konstrukcji kodów, ale pobieżnie omówię
tylko kilka dobrze znanych przykładów. Po pierwsze, okazuje się, że nie jest wcale
kluczowe, żeby kod toryczny miał periodyczne brzegi, czyli możliwe jest wycięcie tylko fragmentu kodu torycznego i
rozłożenie go płasko na dwuwymiarowej powierzchni, a nie na torusie. I to, co uzyskujemy robiąc to, nazywa się surface
code'm. Na przykład jeśli wytniemy krawędzie siatki we wzorcu pokazanym tutaj, z tak zwanymi szorstkimi krawędziami na
górze i na dole i gładkimi krawędziami po bokach, i odpowiednio uwzględnimy przypadki graniczne dla generatorów stabilizatora,
to dostajemy kod, który tym razem może kodować tylko jeden qubit, ale kod mimo to dziedziczy najważniejsze
cechy kodu torycznego. W szczególności nietrywialny niewykrywalny błąd dla tego kodu musi
odpowiadać łańcuchom błędów, które albo biegną od lewej krawędzi do prawej, albo od góry do dołu,
w zależności od tego, czy są to łańcuchy błędów X, czy Z. Możliwe jest też wycięcie
krawędzi po skosie, żeby uzyskać tak zwane obrócone surface code'y, i może to być pomocne przy zwiększaniu
ekonomiczności kodów pod względem liczby używanych qubitów. Na przykład jeśli weźmiemy ten surface
code i usuniemy część qubitów, zostawiając kwadrat zorientowany po skosie, dostajemy kolejny surface
code, o ile określimy generatory stabilizatora na granicy we właściwy sposób. Diagramy jak ten są
pomocne w precyzowaniu definicji generatorów stabilizatora, gdzie czarne kafelki – w tym zaokrąglone na krawędziach – wskazują generatory X-stabilizatora,
a białe wskazują generatory Z-stabilizatora. Te na granicy to nawiasem mówiąc tylko 2-qubitowe generatory XX
lub ZZ stabilizatora. I często zobaczysz te diagramy obrócone o
45°. Inną interesującą klasą kodów, które też należą do ogólnej kategorii kodów topologicznych, są kody
kolorów. Nie będę wyjaśniać dokładnie, jak działają, ale jednym ze sposobów myślenia o nich jest to, że są geometrycznymi uogólnieniami
7-qubitowego kodu Steane'a. Rozważmy więc kod Steane'a 7 qubitów i przypuśćmy, że ponumerujemy nasze
qubity używając konwencji porządkowania Qiskit, jak pokazano tutaj na ekranie. Możemy następnie skojarzyć te siedem
qubitów z wierzchołkami grafu pokazanego tutaj, i co stwierdzamy, to że generatory stabilizatora odpowiadają
kafelkom lub twarzom tworzonym przez krawędzie grafu, i dla każdego kafelka zawsze mamy generator Z-stabilizatora
i generator X-stabilizatora działający nietrywialnie dokładnie na tych qubitach, które znajdują się w wierzchołkach tego
kafelka. To jest miłe, bo tak jak dla kodu torycznego mamy geometryczną lokalność dla tego kodu, więc nie musimy
przenosić qubitów na duże odległości, żeby mierzyć generatory stabilizatora. Fakt, że generatory Z i X stabilizatora zawsze działają nietrywialnie na
dokładnie tych samych zbiorach qubitów, jest też miły z powodów związanych z kwantowymi obliczeniami odpornymi na błędy, o których
powiem więcej w następnej lekcji. Kody kolorów to kwantowe kody korekcji błędów, które uogólniają ten
podstawowy wzorzec, gdzie robimy zasadniczo to samo, tylko z innymi grafami. Na przykład oto graf z
19 wierzchołkami, który zadziała. Daje nam to kod, który koduje 1 qubit na 19, i ma
odległość pięć. Są one zresztą nazywane kodami kolorów, bo jednym z wymaganych warunków dla grafu jest to, że twarze mogą być trójpokolorowane, co oznacza,
że możemy pokolorować twarze trzema kolorami tak, żeby nigdy dwie twarze tego samego koloru nie dzieliły krawędzi.
Kolory naprawdę nie mają znaczenia dla samego kodu – mamy po prostu generatory X i Z stabilizatora dla każdej twarzy, niezależnie od jej koloru. Ale kolory
okazują się być ważne dla analizy jego działania. To są więc dwie bardzo dobrze znane
rodziny kodów, ale istnieje wiele innych znanych konstrukcji, w tym opartych na podobnych ideach co te rodziny kodów, jak też
zupełnie innych. Konkretnym przykładem kwantowego kodu korekcji błędów, który został niedawno
odkryty przez niektórych moich kolegów z IBM, jest tak zwany gross code, nazwany tak, bo gross to tuzin
tuzinów, czyli 144. W szczególności ten kod koduje 12 qubitów na 144 qubity i ma
odległość 12. Nie będę szczegółowo wyjaśniać, jak ten kod działa – jest podobny do kodu torycznego, z tą różnicą, że każdy z
generatorów stabilizatora angażuje teraz dwa dodatkowe qubity, które są tylko trochę dalej. Nie ma płaskiego osadzenia
jak surface code, ale ma tak zwane osadzenie planarne, co oznacza, że potrzebne są dwie warstwy qubitów zamiast
jednej. Należy do rodziny kodów zwanych kodami rowerów binarnych, i co jest w nich szczególnie niezwykłe to,
że są znacznie wydajniejsze niż kod toryczny czy surface code, w sensie, że można zakodować o wiele więcej qubitów, tolerując jednocześnie
mniej więcej taki sam współczynnik błędów. W przypadku gross code'u potrzebne są dodatkowe 144 qubity do pomiaru
syndromu, więc łączna liczba wymaganych qubitów wynosi 288, co czyni go bardzo obiecującym kandydatem dla dzisiejszej
technologii. I to kończy tę lekcję, która dotyczyła konstrukcji kwantowych kodów korekcji błędów, w tym kodów CSS, kodu torycznego i
pobieżnego spojrzenia na inne konstrukcje kodów kwantowych, w tym surface code'y i kody kolorów. Mam nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie na
następnej i ostatniej lekcji serii, poświęconej kwantowym obliczeniom odpornym na błędy, która mierzy się z wyzwaniem wykonywania
obliczeń na zakodowanych stanach kwantowych przy użyciu operacji i składowych obliczeniowych, które same w sobie są podatne na
błędy. Do zobaczenia!